alors la troisième concurrente tout
s'oriente et l envie de rigoler comme
moi c'est sandra numéro deux en
applaudissant va numéro d'appel sandra
numéro 2 que si on n'a vu diva vient on
se dit bonjour jai ho 120 ans fait un
bisou et où tu viens là boum boum à
vienne compétition à cannes
seat habitent dans un pays où on fait du
chocolat oui est ce que je mange
beaucoup
j'ai jamais joe cole c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qui fait on va pas y
travaillent dans le chocolat bah ça
c'est un beau métier
alors là ça me plairait d'avoir un papa
qui soit gens voyagent pas ce que c'est
beau tu as déjà voyagé
vous savez que c'est une fille qui est
très malheureuse pas de chocolat